uh for you
give me your RnB Mount Rushmore
oh Beyonce okay maybe
Mary J Blige okay
Laura Hill
um
let me some scissors scissor
yes all females on the Mount Rushmore
yeah yeah for sure not the other guy
from Chicago who's a legend but you know
not the best person who's that Robert
Kelly you say his name no
I feel like that's who I really lean on
when uh incredible you love SOS that's a
great album yes yes she did her you
know and says it's like a Pioneer and
she's like in her own
Lane her own world
um yeah I love scissors oh yeah she
inspired me a lot you know what it is
too is like you know you're an amazing
female R B artist when you can get like
a dude to like appreciate and this is
true because you're you're the same type
of artist where you can like because
there's a lot of female r b for me that
like well this is not I can't relate to
this it's like you know I'm not a
scorned woman so yeah yeah but then when
I be hearing your or I'll be
hearing scissor I'm just in like
yeah and that's that's the beauty of it
but what's so crazy I feel like a lot of
guys are they get like upset behind my
music because I kind of keep it too real
and too honest so I'm glad to have your
support as a guy yeah a lot of guys I
see it all the time like man you know my
lady is mad at me because of you or you
got me in trouble you know okay give me
like a song lyric that might have got a
guy in trouble that day I got a record
don't tell nobody with Jeremiah says
like dropped it a long time ago but to
this day it goes crazy
um what are you saying I'm like like
where's your way the guy's cheating
keeping on the DL you sell you with
the Bros and you out with a oh
yeah so you're at the crib and you
leaving her place pull up to the crib
lie on my face
such as real like that I love to
come raw and like same way the guys rap
and like they drop bombs and that's
how I'm coming for the women I love it
so yeah I'm glad to have some support
from the males
oh how can I overlook so the last
record we just wrapped it that's why
there's another feature with young blue
and it's called stingy
um amazing record you know working with
blue is so you know so easy he's got a
super dope tone too I love his voice yes
very unique come on SO stingy is
dropping really soon it's gonna be on
radio as well produced by airmaker
and that's the vibe you know were you
guys in the studio together for that one
no we weren't we actually uh sent it to
me and uh we kind of just went back and
forth with it until it was right